I actually watched a good friend of mine
that was not a life term inmate who had
a definite date to get out turn green
and died in his bunk prison health care
in the u.s. is broken after serving
their time prisoners will almost
certainly be sicker upon the release if
they even make it that long
Joseph Calderon was in prison for 17
years while serving time in the security
housing unit
I had chest pain one night 7:00 sharp
pains that woke me up out of a dead
sleep Joe wasn't able to see a doctor
the night of his chest pain
it wasn't until two weeks later that he
finally got to see one Joe says the
doctor told me just had a muscle cramp
and sent him back to his cell with
benadryl while prisoners are the only
Americans who are constitutionally
guaranteed to have health care they
often have to fight to see doctors and
get medicine okay so why is prisoner
health care so bad when it comes to
political power prisoners rank pretty
much at the bottom in certain states
they can't even vote and prisoners rank
at the bottom of the social ladder to
American society generally views people
in prisons and jails as deserving of
whatever mistreatment they get there
just isn't the political will to make
prisons and jails more humane and state
and city governments are under
tremendous pressure to make the cost of
incarceration as low as possible low pay
of facilities tends to attract less
qualified doctors much of the medical
care is outsourced to private
contractors who often rely heavily on
unlicensed medical assistants instead of
doctors and it could take months to even
see a doctor one of those contractors
southern health partners only requires
its doctors to spend six hours a week
visiting jails and one doctor may be
responsible for thousands of inmates we
see cases every day of the most horrific
abuse and neglect of desperately sick
people a prisoner told to take Tom's for
what turned out to be cancer nurses
failing to deliver medications in
falsifying records to show that they did
we have one case where a nurse wrote in
the patient's chart that he had them the
final signs were normal and he was at no
parent distress despite the fact that
the prisoner had actually died 10 hours
earlier if they're lucky enough to get
actual medical advice
prisoners might not be able to afford
following it they're still charged for
co-pays and prescriptions their jobs in
prison pages pennies an hour the average
pay scale is about 18 cents an hour so
$5.00 for your medications can start to
add up prisons and jails are designed to
break people down it's all but
impossible to get meaningful care in a
prison setting that is inherently
detrimental to a person's physical and
mental health it's stressful conditions
lack of exercise and a diet full of salt
sugar and carbohydrates don't do much to
help sick inmates you it's not unusual
to see people who are who look 15 20
years older then there are lots of going
so what do you think it seems the real
question isn't should prisoners get
adequate health care but how badly are
we as a society willing to treat people
in American prisons and jails
you